the kovetz 19 outbreak has infected more
than a hundred and forty thousand people
worldwide it's forcing communities to
brace for huge economic and social
changes for many staying at home may
mean still getting work done
communicating with loved ones or perhaps
becoming more tech savvy and while
businesses and stock markets forecast
slow economic growth some tech companies
are seeing an uptick video conferencing
software company zoom is one of the
biggest winners from the crisis removing
time limits for his video chats is
looking to help keep business meetings
and student learning afloat google and
microsoft also announced they would give
free access to video conferencing
services and live document collaboration
to lay and Google's parent company
alphabet says it'll work with US health
officials on creating a tool to help
detect the coronavirus clients and
patients and people that interest can go
fill out a screening questionnaire move
down for symptoms or risk factors demand
for messaging education and productivity
apps are likely to grow and as more
people stay at home other platforms are
benefiting the coronavirus will have an
impact on streaming websites and
services like YouTube Hulu and Netflix
sites that monetize their content will
see significant increases in ad revenue
from increased demand on their platforms
but as the global demand for such
services increases so does the need for
secure accessibility the need for
broadband internet access has never been
more urgent
folks who lack reliable and affordable
connections will be left further behind
people need to be in control not less
secure in the longer term we need better
build-out of fiber-optic networks to
low-income rural and at-risk communities
we need discounted devices and we need
freed up use of spectrum and more
alternatives like community networking
during these times of uncertainty
digital tools are proving to be more
vital than ever as the shift to home
office and schooling becomes the new
reality for many around the world
he'll Mohammed Al Jazeera